The course has essentially two components. In
the lectures you will learn about cutting edge
research problems in computer networking and you'll also
gain the ability to come up with your
own problems. We'll pick up the basics along
the way as necessary. In addition to the
lectures there are also a number of problem
sets or assignments that you will work through.
As you work your way through the course. The
problem sets and assignments in the course will give
you proficiency with the tools and technologies that are
state of the art in the research community. That will
allow you to follow through on the research ideas
that you may come up with as we work
through various topics in the course. There are tons
of exciting tools to use, and the problem sets and
assignments will help you gain proficiency with them.